I've been feeling depressed since I was
13. that's something's wrong I don't
want to do this anymore I'm just ready
to die at this point I'm bawling my eyes
out I just said out loud Jesus save me
and something happened
the fault dear Brutus is not in our
stars but in ourselves
and sometimes in the Stars specifically
when we look to the stars and compromise
our Free Will and start doing a dance
with the devil that is what happened to
Angela Uchi who dabbled in astrology
hosted a very popular astrology podcast
to the Moon and back
and then got into all sorts of weird new
agey occult things Reiki
manifesting
crystals tarot cards all the rest of it
until she realized it was all really
really bad and gave it all up
here with me is Angela Uchi now the host
of the heaven and healing heaven and
healing heaven and healing thank you for
coming on the show thank you for having
me happy to be here we chatted a few
weeks ago on my member block at the
daily wire and I said
this needs to go way way longer I want
to know way more about what's happened
because people write into me all the
time and I even have just friends ask me
in my regular lives Michael what do you
know about the law of attraction Michael
what do you know about the secret what
do you know about the crystals and Reiki
and astrology and all this stuff that I
say seems really really kooky and weird
but I don't know anything about it
you do and you say it's not all just fun
and games it gets pretty pretty dark
so I
was involved with occult practices for
almost a full decade
um I had an extremely tragic death in my
family in 2014. we touched on this
briefly when we spoke my grandmother
died I was on a cruise ship in the
middle of the ocean when it happened and
she was like my best friend in the world
I grew up with a single mom did the best
she could love her to death but she
could only do so much so Grandma really
kind of stepped in and took over
with after school care things like that
so we were very very close growing up
she was my everything kind of in
hindsight she was my god
um
and when she died it was absolute
tragedy for me it was the worst thing
that's ever happened and
once that occurred
um
I was desperate for any way to connect
with her to talk to her again to
experience her again
and I didn't know any better all I knew
was my pain and I know now that Satan
kind of capitalizes on trauma everyone I
talk to that's coming out of new age
doesn't have the same story as me but
often there is a pinpoint traumatic
moment where they've started to go down
this rabbit hole and so
I went to see a medium I consulted a
psychic medium after she passed and the
medium knew things that she just really
had no business knowing it was
astounding at the time
and I was I was hooked I was just 100
all in from that point forward and it
just was a domino effect from there I so
the medium had cards
Angel cards oracle cards as she called
them and I bought that same deck I went
on and bought that same deck by Doreen
Virtue who
about five to seven years ago actually
came out and said I'm not selling these
cards anymore God told me that these are
demonic
I can't do this I want to pull back all
of my inventory she had books out she
was like traveling the world she lived
in Hawaii making so much money from
doing this stuff and just denounced all
of it when Christ came to her and so
when I had heard that years ago this is
when I was really deep into it all that
I thought well she lost her mind but
it's kind of a full circle moment I went
out there you had lost your right I had
lost my mind I was I was the kooky one
and so
after I got into cards I wanted to learn
how to develop my own psychic medium
skills so I would buy books about that
and this is all kind of alongside of
self-help getting into like the
self-help kind of culture
that just teaches you off the bat you
know you are your own best asset you you
you you it's all like essentially
narcissistic therapy in all of these
books so I'm doing that alongside
learning about psychic mediumship and
learning about tarot cards and things
like that
um that spiraled into
yoga practice in Reiki because I had
also after my grandma passed decided I
was going to take control of my health
because I was very overweight at the
time I was only 20 21 years old and I
weighed over 260 pounds I was not well
um and I realized I was kind of setting
myself up on the same path as my
grandmother because ultimately it was
her health that did her in
so I don't want to do that anymore
um so I'm learning about self-help I'm
losing weight getting healthy developing
this nice relationship with food and
exercise
and also getting into spirituality so
this is all these moving Parts but the
yoga was originally
um
physical wellness like a way to kind of
supplement my weight loss process but
that very quickly became spiritual the
more I read about it and then I became a
yoga teacher years later and that as I
learned about the history of yoga that
just brought me right into Hinduism and
all those kinds of course because people
think yoga is just stretching or
something you know but really it's a
religious liturgy not not just the kind
of Liturgy of liberal white girls in the
suburbs which is what it has effectively
become in America but it goes back much
further and it's a Hindu spiritual
practice the word yoga literally means
yoke and so in that context it's to yoke
spirit so it's an invitation for
the Hindu gods to kind of come into your
body and a lot of the poses are
specifically
um reenactments or paying homage to
scenes with ancient gods and things like
that and I have to pause you for people
who are going to say well that's crazy
that's insane you think you're inviting
all these Spirits in it's just yoga I
guess I would have to ask those people
hey
don't you think it's a little weird that
in your physical stretches as you are
presenting these things to be that you
regularly chant and invoke ancient kind
of Vedic or Hindu utterances isn't that
a little weird that you go into poses
that are explicitly and intentionally
spiritual
what which of us is the crazy one here
because I'm just reading into this
long-standing tradition what it has
already presented always presented
itself is doing right and that's kind of
a misconception a lot of people have
even Christians that I talk to now say
well what what's so bad about yoga
um
I challenge you go into a yoga studio
and try and say God's name
you can't it doesn't fit you can feel it
when I was a yoga teacher toward the end
I tried doing it and just you can just
feel from the class it's like you're not
saying you physically can't utter the
words right you're just saying no one in
that place it doesn't people don't want
it right I was even told because I used
to put yoga videos on YouTube as well
and I would try and say
um you know let's let God's presence
come into the room kind of just when I
was trying to straddle the fence of both
at the time this was about a year ago so
I would get comments people saying I
don't like that word could you could you
say universe
so it's the whole I don't like that word
can you say moloch please right
so the the yogi concept of God is very
much
Source Universe we are all God mindset
and alongside with what you were saying
with the chanting and things like that
it's not just the chanting it's the
poses themselves they're they're very
unnatural it's very different than just
stretching yeah so if you want to
stretch you can do Pilates right yeah
there's no ums and oz in Pilates and so
I always say that yoga is not a physical
practice of spiritual benefits it's a
spiritual practice with physical
benefits
so it's just so you got into yoga you're
a yoga teacher you mentioned Reiki right
I've heard this word before
again from my kind of white girl liberal
friends and I to confess my ignorant I
have no idea what it is it's it's energy
healing
so the idea is and when I say these
things now I feel like I just sound
absolutely insane for having believed it
so much
um
so it's essentially
you were able to allegedly able to tap
into the universal energy Universal
Consciousness and how that energy is
supposed to be all love and healing and
so you are kind of the vessel for that
energy to enter in
and you lay your hands over somebody on
usually like a massage table and
you facilitate that energy energy
through their body and you move through
their shocker system which again that
that kind of ties into yoga so the idea
is that we have these seven energy
channels in the body and the throat and
the heart and they all operate different
things for us like where our
insecurities are and our self-expression
our creativity Sexual Energy things like
that and so
for instance someone might say
but having kind of really bad cramps
um can you kind of clear that energy for
me and so you could deduct from that
based on where the pain is and the shock
or Associated that
oh you are probably having some sort of
creativity block yeah I'll clear that
out for you and so that's the idea and
you could use crystals to help
facilitate that because all the crystals
of course have their designated healing
qualities supposedly
um I gotta ask sure
does it work or even
does it does it do anything it does it
definitely puts you in an altered state
of consciousness and that's not just for
the person receiving it's also the
facilitator as well sometimes um I would
have really intense because I would
facilitate it and also receive when I
would facilitate I would get moments
where my hands would get very hot if I
was over someone's throat or something
and that was my cue that they that
needed extra attention
do you think there's a physical natural
explanation for that or no my
understanding
is that
it's
supposed to just be the energy
accessible to all of us
so
we all in a way experience if you're
having creativity Block in a way I am
too so that's why I'm able to recognize
it because we're all one kind of mindset
and to answer your question in regard to
does it work it is a Band-Aid on a
gunshot wound it works until it doesn't
and you need more and you need more and
you need more
it really for me would alleviate it's
like taking Tylenol it would just
alleviate the symptoms but not
necessarily fixing problem heroin right
and I always say these things are
spiritual narcotics because that's
exactly what they are you get addicted
to it you get addicted to the highs you
know you leave a Reiki session wow I
feel great I feel so refreshed I'm
cleansed and then two weeks later you
have a mental breakdown and you're like
well I guess this chakra is still kind
of clogs or I didn't cut these cords
from my past life sort of thing there
was always an excuse to justify why you
needed more you believed in past lives
oh yeah I believed a lot of crazy things
I was from the yoga and the Reiki
um
I was at this point where again I'm
studying self-help I'm getting healthy
I'm finally at a place where I don't
hate myself when I look in the mirror
because I had lost over 100 pounds
and this was about
six years ago so I'm still sad you know
I thought I had worked through the
Grievances of my grandmother the best
that I could by getting healthy I
thought I'm eating well I'm working out
why am I still so depressed I'm reading
all these self-help books like so many
self-help books you should have seen my
shelves was ridiculous
um why am I not getting better I'm
journaling every day I'm doing yoga
every day I'm you know if getting Reiki
done I find the people who get into new
age and Reiki and who are really into
yoga
they always seem to read a ton of
self-help books yeah there's a
correlation what's that about uh a
savior complex a self-savior complex
um as opposed to a savior savior right
everything everything is counterfeit
gospel everything all these practices in
one way or another is a counterfeit
gospel
and that is where I'm going to get into
probably the weirdest part of my story
where
I'm up maybe two or three a.m one night
Googling why do I feel
like this why do I feel like I don't
belong why do I feel like I'm almost
like an alien on this planet and so I
find
information journals from people saying
well actually turns out you are an alien
so yeah I literally believe I was an
alien
they're called starseeds
um and the idea is that starseeds come
from
another dimension another star system
another planet another galaxy like I was
mentally ill if you couldn't tell so but
were you mentally ill in you know I
don't know some part of your brain was
firing the wrong way or
or were you just deluded you diluted I
mean this was it was not as though you
know you pop a pill and it fixes a
chemical imbalances you you had just
gone so far down this Rabbit Trail that
it compounded on itself spiraled right
yeah absolutely
so I'm reading all this stuff and it
made sense to me because it said you
know you've always felt like an outsider
because you are an outsider you don't
belong and you came here to help Earth
so the starseed gospel as I call it is
that
you are kind of a light worker that has
observed the state of our planet
and because coming back to this idea
that we're all one energy the universe
is all one
it's like well if this planet is out of
whack then that's going to Ripple
throughout the Universe and create chaos
throughout the universe so we need to
find Harmony amongst ourselves and so
the light workers from different
galaxies come in to Earth to ascend the
collective that's the narrative
um
and we do that with our healing
modalities Reiki and astrology we teach
these things too so it's obviously very
esoteric indeed but
I guess I
I'm only half having trouble because
I've gone kind of down weird rabbit
holes too which we can get to a little
later
I've never thought I was an alien but
I've gone down pretty weird rabbit holes
but in that moment so you're looking
this up and you know this website says
oh actually you know Angela you're an
alien yes what
how how did you persuade yourself of
that like how would that have worked it
Justified my sadness and it gave me a
purpose because I felt like I was
meaningless I didn't know why I was here
I wanted to die to be quite Frank I was
very suicidal flirted with suicide in
high school on and off in college
self-harm I did all the things and
it never got better you know I was like
25 feeling the same way that I did when
I was 15 despite all the work I was
doing and despite how hard I was trying
every single day to just pull myself up
by the bootstraps and feel good
and just wasn't just wasn't ever really
hitting and what I was really looking
for which I know now was God
but
um yeah when I was first learning about
the starseed thing
it was like wow okay this makes sense so
I chose this life I chose to be here I
chose this suffering because it's
teaching me something it's my karma that
I'm working through because when I work
out that bad stuff it helps the universe
with its bad stuff it kind of doesn't
make sense because it not real so
um and it's all kind of self-refuting
because it's like well we're the mess
but we're also the cleanup crew like it
just doesn't really match up like you're
the knot but you also have to untangle
the knot it doesn't make sense so you're
you're not in control at all but you're
totally in control of everything exactly
right exactly and um
with the whole starseed thing that just
got me obsessed with space
um wanting to find my star family I
would do meditations and like walk
through things to try and can like
connect with those beings
the star the star people
did you did you connect I've had
experiences where I felt like I saw
things and um felt things like in my
room
they were always like blue it yeah
really really strange and I have a shape
long like you like like the typical you
know kind of alien that you see in a
Sci-Fi movie but like not scary like
light but what do you think that was
just a hallucination or a to be
perfectly honest a demon yeah that's my
understanding of ghosts
any anything of that kind of story I
don't
there's a ghost in the Bible
is there so when a Saul goes to the
witch of Endor
he saw his outlawed necromancy all the
stuff that we're talking about right now
right and he goes to the witch of Endor
and he says call me a call summon up a
ghost and she says no I can't do that
Saul you know outlawed it in the land
and he goes don't worry about Saul yeah
he him being Saul and so she does and
it's a it's a really curious moment
because she says oh my gosh you've
deceived me because she calls up the
ghost of Samuel and it's a very
interesting moment because it seems as
though the witch of Endor is actually
sort of surprised by what she's done so
it raises the question was she sort of
just a fraud like a dime store Boardwalk
psychic you know who is just selling
nonsense to people and then all of a
sudden she conjures a ghost but
regardless she does conjure Samuel and
then Saul talks to Samuel so we have at
least one example of a ghost so I don't
know a lot of times when people
say they've seen a ghost which has
happened many many times I wonder if
that happened to me too when I was
little it did so well I wonder if
they're hallucinating if it's a demon
but I'm not totally sure there aren't
ghosts too
yeah it's not a hill I'll die on but
um because then you might become a ghost
Fair
I just
with the alien thing specifically I
think that's the Demonic kind of Realm
yeah that we shouldn't really have any
business playing with
and I mean the Bible says the verse that
sticks out to me most coming out of new
age is that Satan himself disguises as
an angel of Light
and that was always what I thought was
coming to me that was my Spirit guides
that was my star family that was my
grandmother you know it's actually
interesting because I had something
attached to me for the past since she
died in 2014 that because I would call
on it I would say please come please
come please come like hug me like I
would let like I would feel hugs I would
feel I would feel something near me
and um after
my conversion if you will I
felt it I was in the kitchen by myself
and I felt it come up next to me and I
said out loud I said God whatever this
is that's been posing as grandma for the
past seven years in Jesus name get it
away from me and never let it come back
and it hasn't been back since
so
you said you saw something like a ghost
when you were a kid was that the thing
that you no I saw when I was a kid what
I thought was my great grandpa
so
it was very very young at the time
and then I kind of that really spooked
me so I it would kind of like block that
out but I I always grew up with this
interest in the Paranormal so there's
something there too I always sought out
scary movies for some reason now I kind
of want no parts of them like why would
I entertain it even yeah but I always
sought out scary movies and like was so
big on haunted houses like wanting those
Thrills and I and when I reflect on that
I wonder what that was like why was I so
interested in
terrifying myself essentially
um
or being interested in demons but
anyway the starsy thing led me to space
which led me to astrology which was
really my
my Niche I
fell in love with astrology because it
kind of explained why I was the way I
was that alongside the starseed
explanation
because it was you know oh I'm such a
sap because I was when I was born the
planet Venus was in the constellation
cancer that explained okay great like I
started to have answers for why I am the
way I am why am I so sad why am I more
prone to these patterns why do my
relationships play out in this way
things like that astrology was starting
to give me the answers and just just
going in and in like just deeper into
myself which was deeper into the occult
essentially because I just couldn't get
enough of what astrology had to offer me
um
so correlating that with my starseed
thing I would tell people on moon and
back podcast I would tell the audience
that
we all chose to be here
it's the karmic journey of course we all
chose to be here to help the collective
Ascend to help Earth rise into 5D
Consciousness and out of this stagnant
3D
and so
we thus chose our birth chart we knew
that these planets would influence our
lives and we chose that because we
wanted to learn specific lessons
and we wanted to be able to teach
specific things and help other people in
certain areas and Foster these sorts of
relationships whether it be with money
or with people or with anything so it
it gave me again that savior complex
that's what I always say it's just so so
you chose it right you don't remember
choosing it and apparently you chose a
kind of crappy alignment of everything
yeah
so it just made me feel better about my
suffering essentially it was like like I
said it was a Band-Aid on gunshot wound
I was miserable but at least I oh okay
it makes sense why I'm miserable I'm
supposed to be I'm working through it
it's it's the process and you know it's
like that interesting again doesn't make
sense it's self-refuting because it was
always
what's taught with these practices
is that everything is a process all the
time but also you're going to achieve
enlightenment eventually so which is it
yeah next week it's going to be just the
day after tomorrow that's when you're
gonna and it's just when I look back
it's crazy how
I've just never grasped any of this in a
logical rational mindset and it's ironic
because now people think I'm crazy yeah
I was going around saying I'm an alien
and that was fine but now I love Jesus
and I've lost you're totally nuts I'm a
clown were you at the time into any of
the new age Guru types I don't know
anything about these people but I'm
thinking of Deepak Chopra yeah I was you
were I was who were you into and I was
into Deepak Chopra I was into Louise Hay
um
there's a teacher on Youtube yoga with
Adrian and no disrespect to her but that
she was my yoga Guru
um Eckhart Tolle who wrote The Power of
Now and actually a new Earth
um a lot a lot I had a lot of names on
my shelves for sure The Four Agreements
it's one of the books who's that by I
can't remember the name of the author
there's another interesting book called
conversations with God by Donald Walsh
and
or well something along those lines
Donald something he wrote this book that
he claimed he was channeling God and God
was talking through him and essentially
the entire book is like refuting the
Bible yeah and it's funny because it's
like this it's Bible thickness
and God just threw this man said
actually everything else was a was wrong
this was wrong this is how it is now
yeah
wow and I liked it because it was all
about honoring your truth which is
the biggest thing with new ageism
is
honoring the self and you know this has
I realized that new ageism is everywhere
it's in politics like yeah
well there was that Obsessed the new age
lady that explicitly New Age lady
Marianne Williamson ran for president in
2016. she was she was talking about
astral forces and all this kind of
really
specifically New Age lingo on
presidential debate stages yeah that's
insane I think Nancy Pelosi said
something recently about Mother Earth
and how powerful she is yeah
Nancy who who pretends to be a
practicing Catholic though she doesn't
uh accept Church teaching on
non-negotiable yeah Central issues right
it tends to be at least right and I was
thinking in the context of even
abortions because people it's all my
body my choice it's my truth it's mine
there is no right or wrong because I am
the author of what's right or wrong in
my life and in my body and that is
everything that new ageism is about and
transgenderism too right my true self
has nothing to do with objective reality
it's just whatever I say it is and I've
seen how
kind of the culture's obsession
Culture by the way the culture's
obsession with
honestly just
kind of dismantling God's order
like why is that like there's got to be
a reason for that and Hollywood's
obsession with the devil and how Jesus
Christ is The Only Name we blaspheme
people never scream out Buddha when
they're upset you know what I mean like
like it's never that Buddha damn it yeah
no one says that right and no one gets
triggered when you say anything about
Muhammad but the name Jesus Christ yeah
people flinch
it's almost like there's something to it
you know what I mean there are there is
a group of people that gets a little
triggered when you uh say negative
things about Muhammad but broadly in a
broad context it's you know there's
there's one above the mall that is most
mocked
um is Saul Kendrick Lamar recently with
the
I I don't think I've ever seen Kendrick
Lamar I saw something on Instagram where
in one of his music videos he's like
walking on water and he's like on a
cross he has a
Crown of Thorns wow yeah or a little Nas
ax he did right the whole video where
he's
basically having sex with the devil and
everyone said people are being extreme
for that but look it's not extreme
because this stuff gets into minds and
it's just a slow drip well there was a
guy he's the deputy monkey pox
coordinator at the White House now
and he's taken photos of himself wearing
leather pentagrams on his chest and
apparently seems to have a pentagram
tattoo on one of his pecs and you have
to wonder you say okay if I'm the crazy
one because I'm noticing this because
I'm observing these really weird
specific satanic symbols
that guy's got to be way crazier for
putting it on his body right how come
how come I'm the crazy one for noticing
he's not the crazy one for doing it
right right it also makes me feel better
that even though I thought I was an
alien I was never uh the deputy of
monkey pox
he never won you don't want to be
coordinated
um yeah I it's just everywhere and I
think it's really important to talk
about for that reason and a lot of
people think I'm extreme I lost I lost a
lot of friends when this happened
because
ultimately the common denominator of our
relationship was sin all practicing
divination constantly together whether
it be a moon circle or Reiki or tarot
cards what's a moon circle
um
so
my obsession with astrology was really
centered around my fascination with the
moon a lot of the time I just
I have some of my old Pockets I was
enamored with the Moon
um because the new moon was always
supposed to represent like new
beginnings and setting intentions and
then the full moon was always what I
would say on my podcast the time when
the moon is in its full illumination so
it's kind of shining a light on
everything that's blocking us from our
intentions that we said at the previous
cycle and so now with the full moon we
can release that and so the moon always
falls in it might be a new moon in Aries
and so Aries is supposed to be like the
sign of beginnings and initiation so if
it's a new moon in Aries that's a really
good time to start a new business
adventure so it just always it gave like
a criteria for my life sort of patterns
to follow
um again kind of instilling purpose in
me because I felt like I didn't have any
then just a scheme okay I do this this
month and I do this exactly this is
escapism
um so the moon circles we would gather
me and a group of girlfriends we would
gather every new moon and every full
moon and we would do just that set
intentions or release and this sounds to
me like
witchcraft like a coven is it is that
what that essentially we would never
call it that because it's really
interesting how
even in the realm of new ageism you
understand that there's negative energy
and negative and demonic influence like
you know why is it that every time we
had to do we did rake gear every time we
did a moon circle every time I practiced
with my crystals or my tarot every time
I did yoga why is it you always have to
pray for protection
why is it you always have to call in an
angel team why is it you always have to
set up
pillars of light around the room like
it's why do you have to prepare yourself
for the worst with all these practices
it's kind of like the same thing with
psychedelics because that's also mind
all altercation right kind of the same
thing and you kind of have to set your
intentions with that too it's all these
things that you have to be really really
particular with you have to follow all
these steps or you could do it wrong
like Sage the room because you know
demons are scared of smudge definitely
uh and for people now who are going to
call you crazy for criticizing all this
stuff people call me crazy for saying
you know actually people do practice
Witchcraft and they say Michael you're
crazy what an insane thing to say
you did it like you did it you saw it
you participated in it it's so again
it's one of these where I go back to why
am I crazy for noticing it
but they're not crazy for doing it
they're actually doing it well the Bible
has the answer to that because because
Satan blinds the minds of unbelievers
and because Satan is the prince of this
world
right and so
you know that's something else that kind
of started to wake me up to
the idea that there is
theistic God specifically the Christian
God
because in 2020 when
um everything went down I was also I was
a seething liberal at the time as well
so I mean it's all connected it really
is because you go to an abortion rally I
guarantee that girl who's naked giving
the middle finger that says F you my
body my choice I guarantee you go into
her bedroom there's a mandala on her
wall like just
what is that by the way it's just like a
the tapestries with like the circles
with all the flowers yeah and it's weird
yeah but I never knew what it was called
they're just like sacred geometry kind
of so it's funny though when you said it
just from the sound of it I thought yeah
okay I kind of get the idea of what and
I'm sure she does because
people try to be conciliatory and nice
and say listen you know a person's
religion has nothing to do with their
politics and you can be uh you can be a
total demon worshiping Pagan you know
conservative and you can be uh Orthodox
Christian uh liberal and but in practice
I've just that just doesn't happen yeah
right yeah
and that's that's what I mean because in
2020 when everything went down I was
obviously had nothing but time on my
hands when I was in quarantine and that
I hit
I hit a rock bottom
um another flirtation with suicide in
that time
but
something that I did with that time was
I started for the first time in my life
began to research things and like this
is when the George Floyd thing happened
to so that kind of sparked something in
me where I was recognizing
inconsistencies
following a lot of Candace Owens at the
time and
um it's actually when I learned about
the daily wire around that time and so I
got curious about things and why the
world is the way it is and what's going
on in the government what's going on in
Hollywood
um oh maybe Trump isn't
crazy mean orange man after all you know
and I got really hungry for the truth
and so I started to be more vocal about
that online like exposing things
as I saw them come up and sharing really
unpopular narratives but true narratives
and that thirst for truth you know I've
always been someone who asks questions
I've always been someone who wants to
know more it's
what led me to self-help I wanted to get
better it's what led me to new ageism I
wanted answers I wanted healing
and my when my politics began to shift
my spirituality did kind of shift as
well where I understood you know
everyone's obsessed with Satan for some
reason like what's that about if Satan
is their Obsession there's got to be a
reason oh because there's a counter to
that it's actually God and so there's
something there and this is when I began
to understand that there's a spiritual
warfare
so understanding biblical Concepts but
still with the backdrop of Hinduism
where I thought it was just Duality it's
just this state of the universe is good
and evil and it's kind of like a
Battleground for who's going to win you
know is it going to be this
5D Ascension that I talked about earlier
or is it going to be like we just get
worse and worse and worse because the
the evil energy and that's the word I
would use evil energy was winning
whereas the good energy was losing
um because I didn't subscribe to what
the Bible says you know at the time so
I at least began to understand things a
little differently understand that God
was there
and that again truth search I tell
people a lot that if you are hungry for
the truth you're going to land on Jesus
eventually yeah because he's truth right
you can you can go down all these
different paths but you're going to find
inconsistencies everywhere else and
that's all I did for 10 years
I took the long way too you know I was
an atheist for about 10 years atheists
kind of weakened to a sort of agnostic
by the end of that and so I attest to
that a lot of parallels actually to I
mean I never was a part of any you know
covens worshiping the moon or anything
but I got into some pretty weird stuff
and went down weird intellectual paths
and I would say basically it's kind of
13 to 23 that was my real period of
apostasy atheism agnosticism uh it I
remember when my you mentioned your
grandmother dying that was a big moment
when you started to explore these things
I remember my mother died I was 17 years
old and I was so
I I so wanted to talk to her that I
Googled it I said how do you talk to
Deadpool yeah and I knew I know that you
can't talk to dead people or that's what
I thought then
now I wonder if you can talk to dead
people or at the very least you can talk
to Demons masquerading as dead people as
has been attested too throughout all of
human history and but I I started
Googling it and it's it's very tempting
when you're when you're so vulnerable
and you're so desperate for something
you'll you'll reach it anything I mean
you'll go to any kind of crazy length at
all and uh you know I on that particular
path I I never didn't go nearly as far
as you did down it I probably just gave
up after not being able to you know re
your spiritual you know voices and
things like that but you can really get
into some really weird stuff the fact
that you mention this obsession with
Satan is so interesting to me because I
I sometimes you'll well if I point out
hey why is that government official
wearing a pentagram
oh Michael that's no big deal it's just
a symbol yeah I think well right but
symbol the whole point of a symbol is
that it symbolizes something right and
so that that's a symbol of the devil
which seems to me to imply
that I that there is such a thing as a
devil or at the very least that this guy
thinks that there's such a thing as the
devil and either way it's pretty weird
that he's wearing that symbol isn't it
and people are just very quick to
write it off just like now you know
there's it's it's seeping into into
schools and into kids curriculums and
even into their play time there's like
yoga Barbies and things like that
and my one friend works at Target and
she was showing me pictures there's it's
like My Little Pony witch thing like you
know cast your spells it just seems it
seems so innocent yeah but it's not and
that's the point and again it's that
Satan masquerades as an angel of Light
it's a deception so so you're all the
way into being deceived but we still
haven't gotten to the part where you get
out of it right that's how did you get a
great point
um
so
it's actually really funny it started to
happen around this time last year around
October of 2021 so this is very recently
very recent it's been a really wild year
I actually saw you guys at Backstage
Live last year at the Ryman and I
messaged you something about message me
yeah I messaged you something about
their about how great it was and then I
was like oh it's a shame that Mercury
retrograde made all the equipment bust
because your mics kept going out and I
was like oh it's because Mercury's in
retrograde
anyway well to regress a little I was
like I mentioned you know at this point
I'm 27
this time last year I was 27 and
I'm just sad I am so sad still I'm doing
everything still it's just like pattern
after pattern after pattern just things
not I'm just never healing like I'm
getting these little spurts of it's
getting better but then crash and burn
worse and it's just a hamster wheel that
I'm on at this point not understanding
what even the point is anymore so I had
this total breakdown moment in my
kitchen crawled up on the floor like
ready to just say like this is like what
what am I going to do from this point
forward like I don't I don't feel like
this in another 10 years because I'm
like rationalizing how again I'm 27.
yeah and I've been feeling depressed
since I was 13. that's something's wrong
that's a lot I don't want to do this
anymore I'm just ready to die at this
point I'm bawling my eyes out and like
you can tell I get emotional I think
about this but
I don't know why I need to do this how I
need to do this I've never no one's ever
told me to do this
but I just said out loud Jesus save me
and something happened when when I said
that uh things just started to change
like overnight and that sounds it sounds
bizarre but that's God I
my heart started to change almost
immediately
um and I want to mention this because I
don't want to forget it because I want
people to remember how important it is
to pray for people my best friend
since we were babies she's been
Christian and I've known her since I
don't even remember meeting her we were
so small
she's been Christian our whole lives and
she's been praying for me the whole time
like two decades of prayer that she
finally saw come to fruition so I like
to share that with people because
um I'm told a lot that it's very
encouraging because there's people that
others know who they just never see
coming out of whatever hell they've been
trapped themselves in and finding God so
I just wanted to touch on that that in
the background I have someone
praying for me the whole time right
um
now after I called out to Jesus
I can't explain it I just wanted to know
more about him because I felt different
inside it wasn't 100 yet but it was it
was something it was something that was
tangibly different than everything else
it didn't feel like
a high
like everything else did it was the word
I was using before I even knew that in
the Bible it says God does not give us a
spirit of fear but of sound mind the
word I was using was sound I was saying
to people around me I can't explain it
but I feel sound
just it's not like static all the time
inside
and so so you had been on with all of
these other kind of Flights of Fancy
you'd have this intense high you're
describing it with Reiki you'd have this
real high feeling but what you're saying
with this conversion to Christianity you
felt
normal normal that's the difference
right one makes you feel elevated and
wild and kind of crazy the other one the
craziest part of that is
finally you feel normal just normal yeah
just
which was probably a rare feeling for
this it was it was so rare
um
and I wanted to read the Bible because
you know oh that's the one thing I
haven't done I've read every other book
in the world
and I'm seeking out more books to read
but this one's finished and it has all
the answers but that's the one I would
never touch because oh that's
um that's the patriarchy that's
that's man you know convoluting it like
you know I believed all the myths
without ever even researching them about
the Bible I just whatever anyone said
about it I'm like yep that's BS doesn't
want to go there paperback trash by
Deepak Chopra that's the truth that's
the word but the uh enduring font of all
culture like we have more documentation
in the New Testament than like Plato and
Homer but that's not true yeah right
this thing that this guy wrote 10 years
ago while tripping on acid this must be
it this must be the answer to my life
yeah my Millennial friend who went to
burning man I'm sure he's got way more
insight than Isaiah right it's just
insane the things I believed and I feel
so sorry for that version of myself and
I
I tease and you know we laugh I do my
heart breaks for people that are
deceived by this and people that might
watch this and think like
that girl's all lunatic like probably
have turned it off by now but
yeah I'm not correction I was a lunatic
exactly because I was there and I I used
to think my best friend for instance oh
she's too rigid she's too this she's to
that she's boring like I would she'd
come to a party maybe she'd have a drink
I'd want her to drink more I'd you know
I'd always get us in these bad
situations growing up like I'm the one
thrill seeking I'm the one wanting to do
all the bad stuff she's the one wanting
to
the normal moderate and moderate and
conservative and just
anyway I
um
got my hands on a Bible I got two in the
same day actually it was kind of funny
how that happens I went to church with
my best friend she took me for the first
time and
it was very unlike the church I had
remembered growing up because I went to
church a couple times Catholic when I
was very small I went to Catholic school
for a little bit when I was younger
nothing landed I was bullied a priest
screamed at me it's a long story many
such cases I I always like to say that
uh especially from the era that we grew
up in I think it was a great blessing
that I didn't go to Catholic school
because I'd almost certainly be an
atheist to this day you know rather than
I went to all these kind of liberal
Public Schools so of course now I'm a
Catholic that's the way it works that's
funny yeah
I um I went to this church with her and
I was
I was just enthralled with the way the
pastor was speaking he was saying things
I'd never heard kind of religious if you
will figure say before he was talking
about the state of the world just
talking about everything that we were
just talking about how the corruption is
the way it is because everyone's serving
you can only have one of two masters
it's either God or the other guy like
there's no other option because even if
it's yourself well if you're a slave to
your flesh and your desires you're thus
a slave to sin and we all know who loves
sin right so it's just yeah it's
something that I think even a lot of
conservatives and especially libertarian
flavored of the conservatives kind of
misunderstand because we talk about
Freedom these days it's just you do
whatever you want but that isn't that
certainly not the Christian
understanding of Freedom right the
Christian understanding of freedom is
that it is not the ability to do
whatever you want but the right to do
what you ought because as you cite the
man who sins is a slave to sin and so if
you use your freedom to shoot heroin or
look at porn or do whatever or any kind
of Vice that there is you're just you're
going to lose steadily your ability to
resist that Temptation and you become a
slave and it's just so interesting that
Paradox that you mentioned because
you know I had thought again the
misconceptions about the Bible oh it's
controlling like why would I ever want
to follow a God that tells me what to do
why would why would a god that is love
ever do that because my understanding of
God was this pantheistic God of source
and we're all God and we all have God
within us and so I didn't
like it it's really what it was it was
never the basis of is this true which I
didn't like it because it didn't make me
feel good and that's what new ageism is
it's I want to feel good now so
um well everything you're talking about
you're focusing on the subjectivity of
it all on just how you're feeling and I
think you're rightly observing that it's
all just total self-obsession and the
reason everyone who's into all these
things they always have a ton of
self-help books because they're much
less interested in the truth than they
are in themselves and it's narcissistic
spirituality yes but my question is and
it gets right back to Mercury being in
retrograde why our microphones didn't
work is there
an objective reality to these things
whether we're talking about the Reiki
heat or whether we're talking about
Mercury being in retrograde and screwing
up my production equipment
is there something to that even outside
of our own delusions and the narratives
we tell ourselves I think yes I I don't
I don't think it would be in the Bible
if if it weren't if God didn't know what
the dangers would be
there wouldn't be a warning label on it
he's not saying don't consult
astronomers and necromancers because you
know it's just a dumb stupid waste of
time right here right I think he's
saying don't consult astrologers and
necromancers because there's an actual
danger here of compromising your free
will or whatever talking to Demons
it's it's real I mean and that's the
draw to it then that's I say this all
the time is that there's just enough
truth to get you hooked on the lies
forever
so where is the distinction if if you
are saying that there is something to
you know
the placement of the Stars into how
things are working on Earth which which
we know is true in as much as we know
that the moon has certain physical
effects you know depending on its
placement on Tides or on the Earth right
and we know that would that's a very
literal physical example of something in
a very limited way but then even from
the Christian Perspective we believe in
Providence we believe in history we
believe in a divine order to the
universe we believe in coincidence and
in coincidence
very often not being mere happenstance
but in being part of God's plan things
happen for a reason in God's good time
that's a very Christian Perspective but
there's a ton of overlap between that
and you know the way the
stars are positioned so so what's the
distinction between the truth of of
astrology and all the rest of it and the
lies that go along with it
well ultimately it's all kind of
determined by Man by fallible man I mean
all of the the whole backdrop of
astrology is really heavily based in
Carl Jung's psychology astrology is
Astro psychology
so thank you for calling out Carl Jung I
hate it when conservatives get really
into Carl Jung no he was an occultist
also could you give a little background
for people know the name not much but I
know he was an occultist and he had
um
there is Helena blavatsky she was
kind of like one of the mothers of new
ageism because new ageism isn't new
which just that's just kind of like the
rebranded term for satanism
but she herself was um a luciferian and
she said that Lucifer is
kind of like the Pinnacle of Liberation
yeah
these are the people that are all
connected with one another
and so astrology is taking Carl Young's
teachings as a man who's connected with
these kinds of people
or these kinds of people are following
his beliefs and vice versa
so you have to you have to look at the
source first of all and I always like to
go back to that because people try and
fight me on it well
because I tried to do this too when I
first started to come around to Jesus I
wanted to so badly keep my astrology
and so I was like okay
well exactly what you just said well God
put the moon there God put the stars
there God put the sun there this way
God made me born this way because I was
at that point able to let go of this
narrative that I came here to do it it
was oh okay God gave me my birth chart
so I was trying really hard to reframe
Christianity and so you can see it's
still like self-obsessed narcissism
because I think I have the answer still
I'm going to Rebrand Christianity as as
an astrologer and bring God into the
Forefront like my intentions were good
but I tell people all the time that
saying is true the road to hell is paved
in Good Intentions and I had that
um I mean for the record I think most
people in new age do I was a sad girl
just wanted to feel better and help
other people feel better too and that's
90 of the people I knew that's the same
thing they're not bad people they're
just heavily deceived and thus children
of Wrath unfortunately
so
I wanted to be the Christian astrologer
and start teaching through that lens
but the thing is you either believe what
God says or you don't and it got to a
point where
I
was in Isaiah 47 where it talks about
astrologers you know bring them forth if
you think they can save you go ahead
and watch them burn in their own fire
because they can't save themselves so
right how are they going to save you and
when I read that something
because the Bible's alive it speaks to
you it convicts you like nothing else
can and when I read those words
it just it
the Holy Spirit just came over me and it
was like I can't do this anymore right
like I can but it's not what God wants
me to do he's warning me against it he
doesn't want me to practice divination
that's exactly what it is it says in
Deuteronomy 18 that you're an
Abomination the Lord's eyes if you're
doing that I don't want to be an
Abomination to God that made me feel
it just made me feel so ungrateful and
disobedient
um it was kind of like you know a
when you're like a teenager and you
rebel against your parents and then one
day you're in your 20s and you're like
oh they were kind of right is like that
same sort of feeling it's it's exactly
like that right
um it's like oh they weren't letting me
out past curfew not because they hated
me or wanted to bully me because they
wanted to protect me and so coming
around to that idea of God kind of like
that roundabout way as we talked about
earlier
of how all these rules are there and I
don't like the rules but I recognize now
that true love has boundaries and that's
what that's why God tells us to stay
away from certain things and to embrace
other things because his love for us has
boundaries and he knows how we are
obviously because he made us so he had
kind of
sets us up with the perfect manual for
Life honestly you think about marriage
which is the fullest sacramental
expression of love that you and I can
find in this world right and marriage is
nothing if not limits Antonin Scalia
made this point uh jokingly about uh the
the obergefell decision that created
same-sex marriage and he mocked Anthony
Kennedy's opinion which established
same-sex marriage because Kennedy had
said that uh it was this important that
same-sex marriage was this important
Liberty that would expand the right to
intimacy that I don't know where the
right to intimacy is but he says he
found that somewhere in the Constitution
and Scalia said I don't know where the
right to intimacy is but even if we had
one I assure you marriage constricts
rather than expands the right to
intimacy ask the nearest hippie meaning
when you get married you say okay I'm
not going to sleep with other people I'm
only going to sleep with this person for
the rest of my life and so it seems like
a restriction but really it isn't is it
is a Liberation indeed it is a
Liberation from your base desires and a
Liberation from your kind of feeding of
the appetite constantly and it really
does allow you to elevate and to pursue
other things and to share your love and
to and to will the good of the other
person and to give entirely of yourself
to your spouse and so this struggle with
Liberation I find so interesting because
you know the catechism says that the
reason that you shouldn't consult
astrologers and necromancers is because
it is an attempt to to gain power over
time and history and ultimately other
people that when you are going you're
trying to find out the future and the
Stars you are trying to cheat you know
you're trying to get an unfair advantage
to give yourself more power yeah
and self-importance
um something you mentioned that that I
really wanted to talk about actually is
how
because you said the right to intimacy
for gay marriage right so
people that are unbelievers and uh now
now that I'm on the other side of it I
see it so clearly the way other people
try and Converse with me or the things
that people say
to kind of push back on what I'm now
talking about is
well we have rights to this that you
know believe what you want believe what
you want you know whatever morals morals
and things like that so
what's interesting with unbelievers is
that they kind of have to borrow from
the Christian worldview in order to make
their claims yeah
why is that
it's it's just because if you want to
talk about rights well if there are
things that we are kind of entitled
entitled to thank you if we're entitled
to certain things if we're prescribed
certain things then there's someone
prescribing that yeah so where do the
rights go where do the rights come don't
come from me like that's written on your
heart from someone
and so it's a great Point yeah it's
something that I see a lot it's how they
have to borrow from the Christian
worldview in order to make their claims
true
which but but yet they then wish
ultimately to liberate themselves not
only from the moral law but from the
moral law giver and it reminds me when
when you talk about this Liberation
Babble that keeps going around in the
acknowledgments of uh Rules for Radicals
by Saul Alinsky who's one of the most
famous leftist organizers in American
history he dedicates his book to all
sorts of rebels and then he has a little
acknowledgment at the end of this and he
says and I I can't forget to acknowledge
that first Rebel Satan who lost himself
heaven but one for himself his own
kingdom
and you you see that language of
Liberation I mean you actually even see
it in Paradise Lost right when Satan
falls from heaven he's in hell and he
says well forget about that forget about
heaven the mind is its own place and can
make a hell of Heaven in heaven and hell
that's something else with new ageism is
that we've created our own hell
so
it's kind of our job to get out of it
but then
it goes back to lacking logic because
if we're all God and God is love and the
universe is love
then how do we also have
these issues that we have to work
through to get back to love yeah right
if if everything everything's totally
perfect there's no such thing as
original sin it's all good man uh
but we know that the world is fallen and
broken mhm and we are part of the world
and we are Fallen broken
so how are we supposed to fix it mm-hmm
because I get the original Sim version
of the world I get that the before the
fall
right the whole Christian story before
the fall the world was perfect and then
man because he has Freedom exercise that
freedom in a in an incorrect in a wrong
and abusive way and this led to sin and
death pervading the world and man's
kicked out of the garden and we inherit
that this broken nature as a part of
original sin this is just an observation
find me the man who who does not have
this and I'll I'll show you a liar I'll
be pointing right at you so we we just
observe this fact of the world and and
uh therefore man is in need of a savior
and and this creates a basically
unsolvable problem unless God himself
sends his only begotten son to die such
that those who believe in him might not
perish but have everlasting life I can
get that you might say I don't believe
any of that crap Michael but that that
story makes sense yes I I don't to me
the the really outlandish accounting of
it all is that no actually secretly
everything's perfect you just got to get
your chakras a little bit more at the
right angle man and then it'll be fine
that to me seems far more laughable than
the previous story yeah and I agree with
you especially with the new eyes to see
that I have because going back to what
you said the man saying it's our you
know our right to intimacy for gay
marriage okay so what you're
acknowledging there for is that there is
a truth you know it's not only like the
moral law giver but you're acknowledging
that there's a truth that we are have a
right to live within and so in that
context someone might say well yes but
it's my truth and so this is a very this
is very popular dialogue amongst new
agers is my truth my truth my truth my
truth and again that seeps into politics
my truth my truth my truth so it's
relativism it's subjectivity like you
mentioned and it's
self-refuting because well there is no
truth okay is that true my truth is just
as true as your truth okay well what if
my truth is that they're that can't be
true right you're you're already
excluding
by saying that all truths are true
you're excluding people who don't
believe that so it just it's logically
inconsistent and it doesn't make sense
none of it makes sense I noticed I
remember in college some of my liberal
friends were quite culturally
relativistic and they say there's no
such thing as a bad culture and you
can't point to those Aztecs slaughtering
80 000 people you can't say that was a
bad culture how dare you that's so
racist all the cultures are just to be
judged on their own terms by the way
never Western culture they never they
would seem to exclude Western culture
but okay putting that aside to say we
have to accept and embrace all of the
cultures and also there's a rape culture
going on on college campuses and we need
to stop the rape culture I said hold on
right if you're telling me we have to
accept all the cultures
and then there's this rape culture are
you you're telling no okay obviously we
have to not accept certain cultures so
if that's the case then don't we have to
come to certain decisions about these
things don't we ultimately need to say
okay do this don't do that this good
this that bad God Good Devil bad go to
church exactly don't we have to say that
exactly at some point but no one's doing
that um
and this push to kind of eliminate
objectivity
is just it's just the unraveling of
scripture before our eyes essentially
um
I
you know I really
for for that whole 10 years just really
believe that
you know I had an understanding of God
but I wanted it to be the God that was
in my mind I created an idol of God in
my head and a lot of new agers will do
that because they do understand that God
Good Devil bad sort of thing but not in
the context of what the Bible says about
it it's in the context of what they want
it to be or whatever
New Age book you're reading says it is
um and it really is all these
essentially it's all Hinduism because
Hinduism is sort of like the
marriage of all religions in one
essentially excluding Christianity and
Christianity is really unique because
it's the only
it's the only worldview that you know
God reaches down to man everything else
it's
man reaching up to try and get to God
it's all about doing the work doing the
work doing the work doing the work and
you know Salvation or the Bible does say
like work out your salvation but that's
not it's not work for it's work out like
exercise practice it right right so it's
a cooperation with God's grace sometimes
how it's described as God's grace comes
all the way down the mountain and you
have the you have the right well you
don't have the right but you have the
ability to turn away from God's grace
yes or to cooperate with God's grace and
so obviously there is an action that
that that is entailed by that faith
without works is dead but it's it's not
an action to earn your salvation it's
right it's a it's an action to cooperate
with God's grace
I say this a lot like when you love
someone you want to commit to them and
make them happy and that's I'm you know
we're in relationship with God you kind
of want to do that for someone that you
love more than anything but
back to the whole Hinduism thing how
it's all it's all relative it's all
you do you sort of mindset it's all
Karma it's all reincarnation so you know
if you mess up in this life
you got the next one to figure it out
because your soul Just Gonna Keep
cycling through and through and through
until you eventually reach nirvana which
is basically Hindu Heaven Enlightenment
if you will
um
and it's um it's just insane when I talk
about these things now like when I hear
these words come out of my mouth I can't
believe that I subscribed to it for so
long
and
it makes me sad but I'm very very
grateful for how I came out of the other
side so from the time of late September
to December of 2021 I was teetering on
the edge of Christianity and new ages
I'm thinking I could do both until I
began to read the Bible more and it
began to really convict me
and there was this moment when I went to
church pastor did an altar call you know
come down to be saved if you don't want
to do it alone anymore you know there's
a there's a father there's a father in
Heaven that loves you send his son to
stretch out his arms in a wooden cross
and die for you I'm just like weeping
um I go down everyone collaps it was
really nice but my pastor came over I
told him a little bit about me he had
actually come out of the New Age
movement like back in the 70s
wow yeah what what sort of denomination
is there or is this it's
non-denominational yeah I'm not really
I'm not I don't think the denomination
thing is our Hills to die on necessarily
I think if you just do what the Bible
says and love Jesus and work through
what the Bible tells you to do
I don't know I think I think in a way
denominations are another way that man
has tried to control God or play God but
don't we if if the denominations
disagree don't we need to you know if
there's something yeah I mean there were
denominations truly
well I don't think they're Christian but
they they identify as Christian and we
live in a trans age so everyone but
there are denominations that deny the
Divinity of Christ right there are
denominations that deny the Nicene greed
and so they might call themselves
Christian but we as Christians would say
no you're manifestly not Christian yeah
and so doesn't that then on matters of
who Christ is what he wants how to
interpret scripture you know 30 000
various denominations around the world
isn't it isn't it our responsibility to
figure it out or is it wouldn't at least
be good for us to figure it out I think
it's our responsibility to just continue
to
preach What God Says in in that sense
but how do we know reciting the you know
just what the gospel says because where
I've come to just really believe is just
what what the Bible says is true and
that it's not going to contradict itself
and God's not going to contradict
himself and the holy spirit's not going
to contradict itself you know people
will say like oh God told me to do this
but if you cross-reference it with
scripture did he really you know like oh
God told me I should still be doing
astrology did he really no what does the
Bible say about it but what about what
about
ambiguous versus for instance Christ
says call no man father
Christ says
in in the same
verse or verses a set of verses suggests
that we shouldn't call people master or
uh teacher
but presumably you don't call your
father by by his first name right or you
know your grandfather or whoever uh you
when you meet someone on the street you
probably call him Mr Smith or Mr Jones
Mister just means Master you go see the
physician you probably call him doctor
Smith whatever
so are you
contradicting what Christ tells you to
do I would say that's more so in the
context of
perhaps a sense of authority over you or
over
your sovereignty
like in that context like say Don't call
someone else
father maybe if they're claiming to
speak through me or same thing with
Master like you know cult Masters don't
right
we're teachers right but you call your
teacher teacher yeah so my only point on
this is not the meaning of that verse
but my my point is
reasonable people could interpret that
in completely different ways so then
as as you are pursuing the truth don't
you feel an obligation or at least a
sort of urgency to figure out one what
it really means what you know what God
really means definitely and two
who has the authority even to interpret
what that really means because if if
it's merely a matter of personal
interpretation then you're going to get
just in this country alone 330 million
interpretations so right so I I agree I
mean I I always hate sort of
internessing squabbling between you know
I don't know the like liberal methodists
and the less liberal methodists or
whatever I mean I think a lot of that is
very silly but it comes from a serious
place which is we want to know God and
know what God wants for yeah right and
that makes sense because he created us
to need him
um we all kind of have this god-shaped
hole and that's why we try and fill it
with porn drugs sex empty relationships
astrology
um
and I think we are once we really know
God we do want to know as much as we can
because we understand it's the greatest
gift we've ever been given and the
greatest love we've ever had but I mean
the Bible does say that
no man will know God's mind so I think
ultimately there are questions that we
won't be able to answer
so we're talking to Jesus well you're
right I mean we could never we could
never comprehend God in as much as if
God could fit in our little heads he
wouldn't be God right because he he
would fit into our kind of finite not
not particularly expansive Minds it
reminds me of there's a legend about
Saint Augustine when he's writing on the
Trinity and uh Augustine's walking on
the beach and he sees this little kid
and the kid has got a clamshell and he's
scooping up water and putting it into a
hole and Saint Augustine says Hey kid
what are you doing and the kid says oh
I'm going to put the ocean in in the
hole and Augustine says you stupid kid
you're not you can't fit the ocean into
that hole and uh the kid looks up at
Augustine and says right and you cannot
fit the Trinity into your mind Augustine
and then is transformed into an angel
and flies away now this is a legend you
know obviously but makes a very good
point you're never going to comprehend
God
however I I don't think then we
necessarily have to fall into a quietism
and shrug our shoulders and say well who
can know whatever you know when Christ
says to Peter here are the keys to the
kingdom of heaven what you bind on Earth
will be bound in heaven what you loose
on Earth will be loosed in heaven hey
fellas you have the power to forgive
sins and whose sins you forgive are
forgiven and whose sins you retain are
retained I mean he's get and go make
Apostles of all the nations I mean he is
giving them a real charge in a real
place in a real world founding an actual
church and so
I I just wonder with that kind of
authority
when you'll become Catholic I guess
that's what I'm saying
um I don't know I I've looked into a lot
of Catholic apologetics
um I don't know if you've heard of Mike
Winger I don't haven't uh he was he was
Catholic turned Christian
and he
he uses like all the scripture as to why
that's so but then he'll have debates
with people that will also use scripture
to say oh well this is true though so
I don't know all I know is that I love
Jesus and I love the Bible and I want to
do what it says and
and you'll figure it out along the way
yes this is what happens I'm still a
baby I know you know I was thinking
about this because my reversion happened
I guess about 23 was kind of the
culminate 23-24 was sort of the
culmination of it and like uh when
Hemingway talks about going bankrupt and
he says it happens gradually and then
suddenly that was like that for me and
it was a lot of reading and a lot of
thinking yeah and the the reason I
I keep coming back to these sorts of
questions on the nuances of this belief
or that belief is because
providentially astrologically perhaps
one of the first people to
make me think about God again was it was
actually my roommate randomly assigned
roommate in college who was a cradle
Catholic fell away his family became
kind of a more mega church Protestant
type family but he was sort of agnostic
and he introduced me to a calvinist
philosopher who was at Notre Dame a
Catholic University who was presenting a
version of an argument for the existence
of God that goes back to Saint Anselm of
Canterbury who's obviously a Catholic
saint but whose argument was rejected by
Saint Thomas Aquinas one of the most
important doctors of the church so
incredibly complex and that would be the
ontological argument for God and so I
really went through this period where I
was reading Calvinists I was reading
anglicans I was reading I was all of
these people even Chesterton who
Catholics love and he became Catholic
but Chesterton started when he wrote
Orthodox he was Anglican John Henry
Newman who's now a Catholic saint he
wrote all these arguments against the
papacy now he hated the Catholic church
and so it was just and I that period of
my life it's like a Whirlwind because I
just felt like the gates had been opened
and this kind of after so much time in
the wilderness this Rush of Truth some
of which yes you know there was some
confusion in there I was getting hit
with some kind of contradictions from
there was it was messy you know but but
ultimately it was a kind of Rush of
truth that was coming on me that I'm
still working out right and it's
honestly really fun yeah it's a fun
process
um after I
went down to
be saved if you will
um although I feel like at that point I
already was it was just kind of
the symbol of it right thank you I
you know he prayed with me for a couple
minutes and back with the moon rituals
and things like that I would always feel
this ache in my chest like this
emptiness this whole this
anxiety this crushing
weight of I don't even know I can't even
explain it it just was like pressure
like I was going to have a heart attack
but my heart wasn't beating fast it
really really intense pain whenever we
would meditate and I would try and kind
of avoid meditation because of that
reason it would happen when I would do
yoga
it would happen when I would pray which
back then was praying to the pantheistic
god
um
well what was that like
like what did you essentially praying to
myself you know
so strange
I am
I
would
I it was never like you know
asking for it was kind of I'm going to
do this
I'm gonna make this happen because I
have God's power in me because I am a
part of source and that is what God is
so it wasn't wasn't just a prayer which
is a request
or an act or an act of worship and
adoration it was a declaration it wasn't
please Lord let this happen I'm going to
do it whether you want me or not you
know right wow and that's that's what
like kind of Law of Attraction thing is
with manifestation it's all I am I am I
am I am which is again counterfeit
gospel because we know who says I am who
I am
and so it's in a way claiming authority
over God or saying that you know better
than God that's what all the new ageism
is I know better than God
um and it's just not true
if it were true we would have figured it
out by now well let's be honest even
even just that declaration that it
centers around I am I am I am seems uh
coincidental right a little too much
yeah
and a lot of it's like that you know
Reiki laying hands in scripture
right there's all these counterfeits
right because who lays hands in
scripture it's Christ and his Apostles
right and who lays Hanson Reiki like you
like yeah me like like me worshiping
my aliens you know what Authority do I
have
um
and that's the thing about Satan though
is that he's he's not he's not very
creative he's crafty he's not very
creative and he can't really make
anything he just kind of mimics things
that's what all the new ageism is just
kind of mimicking godliness and that's
why we're drawn to it because we are
inherently made to need God and so when
something looks like God
and we don't really have the
foundational understanding of what that
is yeah
we get drawn to it and we kind of want
more of it and then we fall down rabbit
holes when we don't have
a Christian Foundation
or any sense of
you know biblical theology at all
because I really I didn't
this this point on mimicry is so good
it's such a good point that Satan
doesn't create anything he just kind of
Apes other things in a way that is
distorted and perverted but but even you
know human beings are mimetic creatures
right we imitate other people we take
when we spend time with our friends we
take on the attributes of our friends
this is why people popularly say that
you are the average of the people you
The Five People You spend the most time
with and we do I mean I could I could
point to aspects that have now become
part of my personality and uh I don't
know the way I speak or the way I dress
or the way I walk and I can say oh no I
think I first got this from this guy you
know when I was seven or I got this one
teenagers are always taking on new
personalities and
mercifully most are discarded at some
point but you know obviously part of it
stays because you have a personality and
so then I I wonder
for the
if we are in a position now where
Christian public Christianity is on the
decline traditional religion writ large
is on the decline and all this weird New
Age stuff is on the increase
for people who don't have much of a
foundation they're very often just going
to
copy what yeah they see what their
friends do yeah I mean I suspect this is
behind the transgender explosion now
more than one in five Zoomers say that
they're lgbtq either Alex Jones is right
and there's something in the water or or
you know turning the frogs gay or it's a
social contagion it seems maybe it's
both but I suspect it's more of the lab
and that's why
when I say it's dangerous it needs to be
talked about that's why because we are
we're complementary beings and we just
do that
and so
you know if you're in school and
this girl's walk around she looks cool
because she has on a zodiac t-shirt and
you know she maybe she brings out her
tarot cards at lunch you get drawn you
think that's cool I want to do that too
so it's important I think to really
teach teach about these things and
expose these things the Bible says
expose Darkness
um so like you said yeah I can't sit
back and shrug your shoulders you have
to that you do have a responsibility to
understand to the best of your knowledge
what the Bible says and what that means
I believe and
especially with kids you know these kids
are so malleable exactly and it's just
so funny how you know we can have
gay pride festivals and drag queen shows
and drag queens and kindergarten classes
and that's fine that's not
indoctrination but taking your kid to
church teaching them the Bible but the
Bible says is true that's indoctrination
like that's not okay
it's not even just that you can have
these Pride parades and the drag stuff
and everything in elementary schools
it's that you have to we now have to
have all this stuff and you you are not
allowed to teach the Bible it's the one
book you're not allowed to teach in
public schools you can teach
the secret you can teach some weird
occult stuff you can teach mind conf
actually you just can't teach
the Bible
it's kind of weird that might offend
somebody yeah
right yeah and I've been told that a
bunch now too is that oh I'm offensive
now I'm a bigot now I'm mean now
I'm not tolerant anymore
and it's crazy first of all how many
people preferred
the me that wanted to die every day
huh
um
and it's also crazy how again it's
you're yelling at me about tolerance
while deploying incredible intolerance
to what I now believe right so thank you
for not being consistent with what
you're saying
because it just it just further makes me
really see that I
I'm on the right path now
based on all the inconsistencies from
people in their like right the pitfalls
of their logic and their belief systems
and how just Christianity really is just
it just makes sense it makes sense it
answers all the questions well this is
the point of theology people seem to
think that theology is just Pie in the
Sky you know Scholastic the school men
just arguing over nonsense
theology is faith-seeking understanding
um
and I guess you could say a similar
thing about the new age stuff without
the understanding right theology is
applying rigor and logic to our
intuitions and to our faith the new age
stuff
completely discards yes logic and rigor
and reason and it just says well man if
you feel the heat you know then it's
probably your chakra is acting up
and it's all you do you I'll do me and
why hello you'll watch as a whole thing
in and of itself you know
Aleister Crowley who's like the father
of modern Satanism essentially who's
also behind people don't want to hear
this
the inspiration of all classic rock and
roll they loved him he's like on Led
Zeppelin covers Beatles all of it kiss
all of them David Bowie loved him yeah
and this is a guy who just loathed
Christianity and like devout Christian
parents have you ever heard of him no of
course yeah yeah and he's you know so
you know all about him and and what was
his rule he said there's one commandment
yeah do whatever you want do whatever
you want and that's in that's in music
that's in culture so that's what I was
talking about earlier how it's like
all these the main all the mainstream
things are all obsessed with following
the doctrines of these people that hate
God and love the liberation of Satan
right so there's
that alone is just something to really
be curious about if you're an unbeliever
or if you doubt you know if you doubt
Christianity if you think it's just a
bunch of mumbo-jumbo that's something to
really take a look at and ask why right
because you could at least observe even
if you're on the fence or you're
skeptical of all of this you could say
you know at least it's kind of weird
right it's kind of weird to wear the
leather or harness I mean even sometimes
people will say especially on the
transgender issue but you could say it
about the crystals or the Reiki or the
astrology you say oh who cares oh come
on who cares and yeah I always flip that
question back and I say
you're asking why I care I guess my
question is why do you care or why do
why do the people pushing this stuff
care so much if if the debate over a
transgender bathrooms comes down to oh
why do you conservatives care I say well
why have you cared so much that you
invest time and effort and resources and
National political campaigns just to let
boys go into the little girls room
obviously you care a whole lot and I
care because one it's unjust and it's
based on a false anthropology and wise
but two the other reason I care
is because these people care so much so
obviously there's something important at
stake here even if it's a little hard to
pick up on at first and from towards the
beginning of our conversation how I
mentioned new ageism is in culture and
politics that's a great example is the
transgenderism because yes they're they
want all inclusive bathrooms and
ultimately this is all to validate the
self whatever you're feeling is true
right whatever you want is is what
should be it's all just constantly
affirming self self self self self self
self nothing outside of self matters
self matters but at that's at the same
token while everyone else needs to
accept that
we need to honor that we need to honor
each other's truths
as the one big cohesive so it's not
incredible it's not about the selves
individually it's really just about
yourself exactly it's about you get to
do whatever the hell you want and
everyone else has to indulge and you
don't want to offend people you want to
be inclusive you want to be loving which
like I understand the mindset especially
because I used to have all those beliefs
like I'm not someone who's just been I
wasn't raised a Conservative Christian
you know I I was living for a really
long time I had feel the burn t-shirts
you know I was
I was practicing all the new age stuff
like I can confidently say I understand
those mindsets and I know that a lot of
it comes from a genuine place of care
for other people care for wanting to
make the best of your life
and of course that comes from making
other people feel good so validating
them and so in a way that's even still
narcissism because I just want to
validate other people you don't want to
you don't want to make anyone feel
uncomfortable why would we ever do that
and that's you know
since being Christian that's that's a
huge contrast that I see versus back
then
because again like I'm crazy now but I
wasn't then
and
my beliefs offend people right just
because I'm telling them essentially
I'm I'm holding the holding them to the
fire and essentially saying you're wrong
and people don't want to be told that
they're wrong because then that makes
them accountable to something and that's
going back to this whole backdrop of
Hinduism I think that's why people are
so drawn to religions like that and to
these new age practices as a whole is
because there's no accountability for
any of them you can never be wrong it's
all you yeah it's all on you it's your
karma it's your life
just do the best you can whatever that
means to you so there's something that
seems comforting there and when you get
back to that word comfort you had been
indulging all of these practices that
were supposed to comfort you and and
solve your Despair and angst that had
been going on for years and years and
years but at the end of it you still
wanted to kill yourself and now you're
doing something that's less
comfortable by the standards of our
culture and
you're at far greater piece yes that's a
little strange it's it's isn't it and I
I just find it fast I really do find it
fascinating how people
help people react to me now
when I you know put things out there
like this is what Jesus says but
again I really just believe what the
Bible says the Bible says you'll be
persecuted you know if they if they hate
me they're gonna hate you I mean you
have to remember that Jesus himself made
pretty radical claims I mean he they
killed him saying that he is God right
they killed him so they're why would
they
like you for you know it just it kind of
makes sense in that in as much as we uh
Endeavor to imitate Christ uh we're
probably a rather pale imitation most of
them and uh you know so you figure well
that's what they did to him the more we
imitate Christ probably the more
suffering and persecution we'll endure
in this world probably again it's not
that it's a certain thing but uh
probably and that's the way it goes
because you referred earlier to the
devil as the prince of this world and
the Bible refers to the devil as the
prince of this world but on the point of
a relationship so you you lose your
friends yeah do you lose all your
friends no actually one of them came
with me out of the new age which is
really cool I was really glad not to
lose her and we go back and forth all
the time in text like even
um this morning when I'm driving in the
airport
she's like the Moon looks so pretty
right now it's just I feel like I can
see every crater and she's like it's
really cool to just appreciate the moon
as God's creation and not as some Idol
that's controlling my life I was like
totally agree it's on that point do you
because you you say that the thing you
shared with all these people and why you
lost a lot of these friends is just sin
you've just been sitting together and so
you give that up but sin is very
tempting even after you give it up yeah
especially after you give it up it's
very tempting do you find yourself
tempted to you know pull out the tarot
cards or anything never no when you know
I'd say the first couple months when I
first
knew of Jesus after I called out to him
for the first time
um I was because I was tempted to stay
in that world that's why I was trying to
do both for so long and then
just came that point one day reading
Isaiah in December I called my best
friend The Devout Christian our whole
lives and I was like I can't do it
anymore I'm going to give up my podcast
I'm going to I don't know what's gonna
happen with that I'm gonna stop teaching
yoga I can't do any of this anymore it's
not that I couldn't like I physically
couldn't like my hands were tied it's
just that I didn't want to yeah your
heart's not in it my heart was changed
right my my mind was renewed
and the hardest part was just doing it
but after I put out my final episode of
moon and back where I said
those same words I don't want to do yoga
anymore I don't want to do astrology
anymore and I was saying like for the
first time I know this sounds crazy this
is I've really met Jesus and I know that
you guys can tell that I've been talking
about it but the astrology and trying to
make it work but it's like you know
round whole square peg it just doesn't
work because they don't belong together
because this is a sin and
I always would tell and I feel so bad
for
um
what I would tell people because I would
I was like a self-proclaimed self-healer
and was teaching others about
self-healing even though I would cry
myself to sleep at night wow so
um how many self self healers so-called
probably do that exactly
but it's okay because it's the process
wow yeah
it's your healing It's Your Shadow work
it's a very popular term the idea of
Shadow work is literally to integrate
your demons like your inner demons so
this is like the dialogue is used it's
you know
integrate your demons fight through your
demons
um make friends with your demons so that
you can understand yeah this is like
stuff I used to teach and believe and
preach
make friends with your demons because
they're teaching you something it's
but it's all in that guise of again
Satan is liberating
so if you make friends with the demons
they're not some scary monster in the
corner you can kind of face it and work
through it so it's good intentions but
it's um
garbage honestly yeah if I had to give
three pieces of advice that's all I
could ever give to anybody certainly one
of them would be don't make friends with
demons even your own
especially especially your own actually
yeah
because again it's like a justification
of
um all things that are wrong with you
or all things wrong that you do kind of
thing like I had really bad patterns
in in my relationship you know and we've
worked through all this romantic my
romantic relationship because I was
Lusty and just wanted to go go do my
thing because you know I was Heavy
before I want to go do the sexual
movement like I'm like having these
conversations show your Wild Oats yes I
like saying like I never had a hoe phase
maybe I should try maybe that will make
me feel better if you're saying this to
your boyfriend yeah like say when he was
my boyfriend at the time when I'm saying
this to him
like this is because I'm like going
through all all these crazy things like
I'm just sad like grasping at anything
that I could so you're saying this is an
amazing moment so you're saying you
you're getting physically healthier at
least and you're losing weight and
you're exercising and you're saying man
I used to be really fat and now I'm
really hot and so listen boyfriend
I want to go sleep around that was like
essentially my mindset but this is like
this is like who I am and again there's
because there's I'm not accountable to
anything I'm just
Living For What makes me feel good right
right so you're not you're if you're not
accountable to God you're certainly not
accountable to your boyfriend yeah right
and when I found
this is like part of the testimony I
don't talk about a lot but he and I have
really gotten into this recently so you
know I can share it more but
part of my testimony a big part of it is
God really saved me from Wrecking that
relationship like
I was I was so tempted by
really bad situations repeatedly like
repeatedly never never like oh maybe
it's like a good guy that could that
could be something it's like it's not
like a red flag it's like a red boat of
a man just like the worst just the worst
yeah terrible guys and like I'd just be
so tempted by it and
that was something that was one of the
very first ways that Jesus showed me
that he was in my heart because he
turned that off like immediately and
like actually let me for the first time
like really fully love this person and
not
wonder what it would be like to seek out
pleasure outside of that
it was really incredible
um I remember in my uh single days
in my atheistic days as well
I similarly was sewing my Wild Oats and
you know
have red blood
sure liked the pretty girls you know and
I remember there was one time after
I don't know the 7 000th
girlfriend let's say uh I I woke up one
morning and I thought
what's the point yeah I thought not only
is this probably wrong you know to be
just kind of casually seeing all these
people and you know engaging in all
sorts of things I shouldn't do but
it's just such a waste of time yeah
obviously it's a perversion of my soul
and someone else's soul and it's not
it's but even before I got to that I
just thought like what up huge none of
this is going to lead to marriage none
of this is going to lead to anything
this is just a
kind of brief titillation and then I
don't know wake up and do it again do it
again yep
and it's crazy because in all that time
too I always knew what I really wanted
and I would question why do I sell why
do I sabotage this why when I know what
I really really really want is just to
be in a
you know monogamous unconditionally
loving trusting loyal lovely
relationship like my grandma and grandpa
had they were married 18 until she
passed you know like
that kind of relationship that's what I
want so why am I going after these
things and it's it just ties back to
this to sin ultimately because
I was a slave to what my flesh just
wanted not what like well not what
really my spirit wanted right I was I
was a slave to it and so I continued to
justify it you know oh back to the
astrology okay like my you know
Mars is in I don't even remember anymore
which feels really good to say my Mars
is in Mars was like the planet of sex
like who decides that by the way the Men
Are from Mars I've been told right so
my Mars is in whatever constellation
that's why I'm so Lusty fine you know
it's just
so that's fine it's fine because this is
how I am it's in the stars and it
exactly and it's something just for me
to work through it's just my own Karma
my own BS so if you don't mind my asking
when you bring this to your uh Ben
boyfriend
what does he say
uh uh no yeah he's literally like
verbatim uh no because I like I try to
like open up the relationship he was
like uh I'm not doing things yeah no
so that's good a lot better these days
there's guys are such wimps that they'll
uh I I I know men who have
their girlfriends say I want to go sleep
around I I like friends of mine have
said like well that's okay you've got to
explore you know that's exactly what
people are saying to me
but that that's like that that is
cuckoldry that like when people say
you're a cockery that's like literally
what that is
that destroys
again the Paradigm that God intended
you know like my whole
my heart totally transformed around what
sex means around what relationships mean
around what marriage means you know
before I was like marriage is a piece of
paper yeah don't see it that way even
for a second now
um another piece of paper it's crazy
symbolizes something right and it's just
it's crazy how much has changed in a
year and you know that's something else
that's very important to my whole story
is because I you know people that have
been watching me like
they don't want to talk to me but they
watch me kind of thing don't follow me
but are in my story views
um
I know that those people can't deny that
they've seen changes in me like just
total 180 from who I used to be and how
I used to act and behave to who I am now
and not only that but all the things
that have transpired like this
opportunity like this is insane that
this is that I'm here I say it all the
time you know this is you you're
welcomed to the Michael Knowles show set
you've made it
the top of the Heap I say it all the
time but it's funny I actually I like
almost kind of
funny prayed about this like couple
months ago I was like
daily wire would be really cool I'm just
saying did you really like seriously
it's really insane similarly how I
prayed
and it's like these prayers that aren't
really
I'm like that's never gonna happen you
know if it's in your will I would really
like if you could set us up in Tennessee
Beyonce gets offered a job that he
didn't apply for in Tennessee and
Franklin exactly where I want to live
you know it's just I love too how you
phrase that prayer because it's how I
phrase my prayers
if it's your will yes and I don't just
do it to be the most Pious boy in
Nashville the other reason I do it is
because Have You Ever Wanted thought you
wanted something and really you thought
I really if I get this one thing then
I'll be so happy and then you don't get
it and then something else happens and
in retrospect you realize man if I had
gotten that thing that I thought I
wanted it would have ruin my life
exactly because that's happened to me
multiple times so I it's kind of in
self-preservation I say
If It Be Your Will yeah I sure would
like this thing but if it's not your
will I don't want that thing because
it's going to screw up my life yeah
that's how I pray too and it's it's um
it's an extra step with me to do that
intentionally because
coming from new ageism it's all like
self-sovereignty and it's my will it's
it's what I decide so
I may get a point and I'm handing it to
you like I I don't want to make it
happen I want you to make it happen and
work through me and he's really been
just like the blessings are just
it's insane just flooding yeah ever
since the the episode release where I
denounced Moon and back
that day it was really funny because I
had spent the whole year trying to build
this thing this this podcast and my my
audience it was just struggling like I
was just struggling and like paying for
ads nothing's like really like it would
like spark but then it wouldn't like pop
off yeah and so I released the final
episode oh here comes the audience you
were looking for it was it was like that
and that's just how it's been with God
ever since it's like when I listened to
him
and I'm not saying like God's a vending
machine like that's not what I'm saying
at all like just you know asking for
things to do it for you it's that
when he is so pleased that you are in
his will
he will really show you what his Will's
all about
and it's been it's just been incredible
you know he he brought so many good
people to me right away to kind of like
scoot me under their wing and like the
guys in cultish I told you about just
kind of give me
solid Theology and um
good discipleship and
just good people because you really you
need to be surrounded by good people
that love God if you're gonna stay
um vigorous on your walk because it's so
easy to get swept up in all the crap of
course yeah so I was really blessed for
that God brought so many good people
into my life and that he continues too
it's really incredible
um and that's what I mean that's I'm I'm
so honored and humbled too that this is
what he's decided to be done for me
um
and that he saw me
in all of the junk that I was in
and he heard me that day yeah you know
and I think back to
kind of how my my when my grandma passed
and
how that felt I was mad at God at the
time and I remember writing about that
specifically you know like saying like
God wouldn't do this to a good person
but it's like I see like all the moving
parts of it now I see
if if that never happened the way it
happened I never would have been LED
down this dark path and it's like it's
like God kind of knew that the only way
he would be able that I'd be able to see
his light if I was if I was
so far in darkness that at that point I
had I literally had nowhere else to look
except up like for the first time in my
life yeah this is the virtue of
resignation and I I remember it too when
I you know I was a teenager and had to
deal with loss
I did come to the conclusion that you
could either react with
anger and a chip on your shoulder
that would probably never go away and
probably only continue to deepen and
chipping or with resignation it's very
difficult to react with resignation
because we
you know always want to be vigorous and
you know I'm I'm of the Italian people
were very keen on you know Vengeance and
uh you know blood boils a little bit and
and so resignation is a tricky one but
it's a virtue for a reason you know and
and uh it also then raises this question
which I guess brings us entirely full
circle to astrology in a way in a good
way
which is
for all my sins
I
have 100 percent
confidence in Providence
I am just so
convinced of of Providence
that
I usually don't get too riled when
something really bad happens or when
something really good happens and it's
probably going to kill my career because
if you want to be a professional
conservative you have to be angry all
the time and I'm not I'm not I'm almost
never angry but that's why that's why I
have I
for every other flaw I just I'm because
I've just seen it you know I've seen it
so clearly sometimes especially when
you're really screwing up God will just
shake you and say like hey idiot you
know I'm here hey hey look you know yeah
my priest father George rutler in New
York has a great book called
coincidentally and in the little flap of
it he says it's a wicked generation that
seeks for signs and wonders
but it's a stupid generation that
ignores signs and wonders
kind of undeniable you know and when you
see that and you say okay there is a
divine order to things
and so all right Shake It Off yeah
that's why I said the beginning that my
grandmom dying was the worst thing
that's ever happened to me and it's the
worst thing that will ever happen to me
because I have that knowing now that no
matter what happens like I'm
first of all Romans believe it's 8 18.
this is this you know the sufferings of
this world can't compare to the eternal
glory and I think of that all the time
if something's wrong and ultimately
God's in control and it's okay
so it's been
it's been I mean for me to say that
versus what I would have said a year ago
a year and six months ago totally
different like totally different
because I would have believed that all
the suffering would be and in a way I
was right in fact eternal
if we if we didn't fix it if we weren't
the ones in Authority if we weren't the
ones that were Sovereign if we weren't
the ones that were in control and now
it's just
nope it's God
you know there's a baker down in my
favorite neighborhood in the world I
guess but it's in the Bronx it's called
Arthur Avenue
it's the real Little Italy in the Bronx
and this Baker I've been going since I
was a kidney wear this hat I love Jesus
and he had a kind of a rough early part
of his life and conversion experience
goes to daily mass and it's just a
wonderful guy and uh as I was reverting
I was thinking of all these very you
know
abstract Arguments for the existence of
God and trying to pursue all this sort
of more of an intellectual path and I
was talking to him about this and he was
kind of
there's a kind of a pivotal moment with
him he goes hey buddy boy you know I do
my best God does the rest
you know buddy I do my best God does the
rest I say oh
that's wiser than pretty much any book
I've read in the last six months
it's not that I'm gonna I'm gonna chart
the stars and talk to the car dealer and
do the necromancy and then I'm gonna do
it and I mean my and I mean my it's now
you know I'll do my best God will do the
rest and honestly it's exhausting to be
in that lifestyle and those beliefs and
I actually had someone say to me once
well it seems like Christianity is the
easy way out because of what we're
saying like oh well if God's in control
then I'm not and it's all in his hands
great I don't have to worry about
anything not like that at all first of
all but his yoke is easy and his burden
is light and that's what they mean
indeed but that's probably not what they
mean that's not what they mean they mean
that well if
you're saying God's in control God is
Providence then what about you like
where's your role in it it's the easy
way out where you know maybe the new age
beliefs are all about
healing yourself and making yourself
better
but
really that's the easy way out because
it comes back to again accountability
right you're not accountable to God
so that's the easy way out because if
you're not accountable to
foreign
the creator of the universe
then you're just accountable to yourself
which is the creator of your chaos
essentially when you love someone you
want to make that person happy and that
carries an obligation and the church is
traditionally understood as the bride of
Christ right and is the bride of Christ
and exactly not it's not
easy
God makes it simple but it's not easy to
walk the narrow road every day
I forget who said it perhaps it was John
Piper who said that
no one like the Christian understands
Temptation because people just whenever
they feel tempted they just give into it
yeah whereas when Christians feel
tempted you kind of got to put your
blinders on and just keep going
and then you sometimes give into it
right because we're going to that's why
that's why Jesus you know died for sin
because he knew sin would be the biggest
problem so
I I mean I fully agree with that and I
and I see now how
all that work you know is always that's
that's the Mantra doing the work you're
doing the work you're doing the work and
that's self-help too
it's like you're doing the work you're
doing the work to heal you're doing the
work to heal it's like okay but for what
because it's all futile yeah because you
can't save yourself I would say you
can't be your own problem your own
solution and it's like self-help
self-love self-hate like it's all one
and the same because ultimately what's
the root
itself and so sometimes I get well is it
wrong to want to better yourself and
like absolutely not of course not I
think that
in in a way we all want to be better
hopefully we all want to be a better
person and I believe that is the kind of
you know the knowing that we have sin
that I digress
um that's the process of sanctification
is is becoming Holier but people outside
of it think that well if if the opposite
of self-love that's self-hate but that's
not true you know I think the opposite
of
self love is is self-sacrifice and
that's really kind of what
Walking with God is in a lot of ways
right there's that that uh idea I forget
which playwright wrote it I figured it
was Shaw or Moliere or I don't know it
was one of those guys said that uh hell
is uh where you have nothing to do all
day but amuse yourself right so it's uh
and it is everyone knows it everyone
knows it who's ever had a vacation from
school by day three you just want to
pull your hair out you're just so we've
got nothing left to do you have no sense
of purpose and so when you were
sacrificing for others when you're
serving others uh you will you you will
have far greater love than when you're
just trying to amuse yourself and that
doesn't mean serving others based on if
they wake up one day and they'd want to
be a boy if they're a girl that doesn't
that doesn't serve anybody it means
serving serving people in truth yeah and
leaving with truth which brings us back
to you there is an objective
reality and there is an objective
standard and there is an objective truth
that the definition of truth
is not fluid or wouldn't be truth truth
is
you know unwavering Rock Solid so there
has to
there has to be a Truth by definition
you either Moor yourself to that that
rock
or you're just floating into outer space
next to all your star systems and your
old alien buddies yeah that's not a
great place to be sure Angela
such a pleasure to be with you we'll
have to have you back into another two
hours
sounds good where can people find you in
the meantime so I'm on Instagram my full
name Angela Marie Uchi it's
a-n-g-e-l-a-m-a-r-i-e-u-c-c-i and then
my podcast is heaven and healing podcast
and that's the actual and symbol and
that right now is on Apple Spotify and
YouTube and
who knows maybe I'll be on the daily
wires you know you're on the daily wire
right now you know what I mean you know
I'm on Instagram at Michael J Knowles
and I'll have to check my DMs more
frequently because I apparently missed
some of them but I'm glad that we could
get you on the show so it's
providentially in any case
thanks for coming it was great thank you
for having me